話に入りますが
今日テーマをみると皆様方
あまり我々に関係ない話ではないかなと思ってらっしゃるかもしれませんし、それは私の勝手な考え方かもしれませんし
なぜならば子供を育てるお母さんたちは大変忙しいので
そういう法話なんか聞く暇がないと思いますから
それでも
これは法話ですから
とにかく私は釈尊の教えをなんとか紹介しようとおもって
話をしていますので
別に自分に子供がいなくても
子供の教育はもう終わっていても
関係なく我々の人生に
役に立つと思います。
ということで
あまりテーマにこだわらなくても
構いません。
大体、まあテーマがどうであろうが、私は大変悪い癖があって
聞いている人々の
理解の度合いを見ながら
話の内容もどんどん変えていきますので
それほど専門的に
子供の心理学やら
教育方法やら言うつもりはございません。
昔は専門的ないろんなところで
日本ではないのだけれども教育機関のところで
講演として話したり
学校の先生たちの
セミナーやらしましたけど
その場合はきちんとした
心理学やら
教育方法・規則に基づいて話をしました。
今日はこちらはお寺でもありますから
お寺というのは一般の方々に
説法をする場所ですから
説法という形で
軽い気持ちで
聞いてみてください。
この話を聞いて皆様のこころがいくらか清らかになるならば
いくらか自分の心を発見できるならば
それで大変結構だと思います。
自分の国でお寺だったら
大変面白い現象があるのです。
大体、満月の日は休日で
お寺は結構人々が集まってきます。
来たら一日中いるのですよ。
面白い現象というのは
「死んで間もない人々」と
「まもなく死ぬ人々」の二種類の人々を集めているのですね。
極端ですけど「死んで間もない人々」というのは子供たちのことなのですね。
過去で亡くなって、現世で生まれたばかりですから。
一応、死の記憶があると思います。心の中に。
もう一つのグループはまもなく死ぬ人々
年を取っている人々なのです。
よくこの自分のお寺・・・ではなく
自分の国のお寺でよくみられる現象なんです。
子供たちが大勢いておじいちゃん・おばあちゃんたちがいる。
真ん中はいません。
我々はすごいたいへんなんですよ。
説法するにしても全く正反対の
生き方。これから生きていこうとしている人々と
生きてきて全部やることが終わっている人々が全部一緒になって
どうやって説法すればいいんですかと。
かなり、大変きついんですよ。説法するのは。
その時、私個人的にはどうするかというと「どちらのほうが調子がいいか」見ているのです。
大体、おじいさん、おばあさんは
疲れているなあと感じたら、子供たち中心に説法する。
子供たちはあまり聞く気が無いな、遊びたがっていると思ったら
子供たちは無視して
おじいさん、おばあさんたちに説法する。
どんなかたちであろうが
両方よく話を聞くんですよ。
おじいちゃん、おばあちゃんたちにしゃべってると
子供たちはものすごく
「自分にわからなかったらよくない」と思っているかどうかわかりませんが
徹底的に聞いているのです。「何を言っているのですか」と。
子供たちに話すをすると、やっぱりおじいさん、おばあさんが大変驚くのです。
なぜならば、「自分に関係ない話だな」と思って聞いていたら、その中に真理がありますから
普段わからない事をよく理解するのです。
何回も経験がありますが、あまり自分の話は話したくないのですが
学校で話をしたことがありまして、何回か小学校の子供たちが
まあ、鬼達みたいにうるさいのですよ。
自分の国だから
音声機器があるわけではないし
ものすごいでっかい声でしゃべらなくてはならない。
そのうえ、子供たちの声っていうのは
全然止まりません。
大人の20人分の声がありますからね。子供一人に。
それでまあ、100人、200人集めて力いっぱいしゃべっていると
そこでは大人にはもうしゃべれませんね。
一回覚えているのは
学校に子供たちを集めて
学校が子供たちに修行をさせているのです。
我々は説法にいったんです。
一応形式的に戒律を受けて修行の形をとっているのだけれども、子供たちはもううるさいんですね。
先生たちは子供たちに「静かにしなさい、静かにしなさい」と一生懸命しゃべっているのです。
私は聞いていたのです。大体15分間、学校の教頭・・・
なんといいますか・・
先生たちが子供たちを静かにさせたいのだと。これから説法だから。ということで。
15分頑張ったのだけれどもかすかにでも声は衰えません。
聞いてないのですね。子供たちは「先生、何をいっているのですか」と。
私は別に困ってなかったし
先生は私のことをしんぱいしているのですね。
それで私は先生に
「まあ、いいですか。私が話を始めても？」
といったら、先生はすごく謝って
「あの子供たちはちょっとうるさいのだけれども、なんとか我慢してください。」というので、私は「はい、わかりました」と。
といって、私が話を始めた瞬間、子供たちは一瞬で
静になるのです。
ということは
子供たちは大人よりしっかりしているのです。
先生何言ってるのですかとみんなわかっているのです。
聞いて、聞いて呆れているのです。
ですから
別に聞かなくても我々は自分の・・・
しゃべりたい放題しゃべって遊んでいたらいいのだと。
でも、このお坊さんが何を言い出すのかはまだわからない。
だから、一瞬で静かになるのです。
その瞬間で子供たちは判断するのです。
おなじつまらない説法か
先生がいっていることと同じくだらないことを言っているかどうか
その瞬間が勝負なのです。
その瞬間で私はさっさと子供たちの興味を引くように
話をひとつ
子供たちにちょっとした質問をして
子供たちを一気に私の話に引きこんでしまうのです。
引き込んでから結構難しい内容
子供たちと一緒に一時間以上しゃべっていたのです。
その一時間
かすかにでも子供たちは声を出さなかった。
私たちは一緒にしゃべっていた。
たまに、能力の差もありますから
ちょっとわからなくなった子供があちこち見たりしていると
隣の子が「静かにしろ」と。
というのです。
それで、終わったら先生達も大変喜んで
私はじゃあ帰りますと席を立った瞬間、また爆弾。
みたいに子供たちがまた叫び始めたのです。
ですから、そこらへんなんですね。問題は。
子供になめられているのですね。我々大人は。
それは大人の負けなのです。
子供はものすごい鋭く我々よく監視しているのです。
私たちは偉そうに「我々、大人は世の中のことを知っているぞ」と。
「子供はなんだ」という感じで。
子ども扱いしているのです。
結局
我々が子供になめられているのです。
だけなのです。
大事なポイントがあるのです。
私は子供達と付き合って一度も失敗したことがないのです。
一度も。
どんな難しい因果法則の話であっても
子供たちに話してくださいといったら僕は話してみせます。
大人が理解しなくても子供たちは理解するのです。
ポイントは子供達に私の心を簡単に読めないようにするのです。
私は先手を打って相手の心を読んでしまうのです。
ですから、我々も
子供に自分の心を読まれてしまったらどうしようもないのです。もう負けているのです。
将棋と同じです。
相手に手を読まれたらもう負けです。
なんでそういうことを言うのかというと、やっぱり我々大人に
年下の人に私は一応「子供」という言葉を置いておきますが。
年下の人々を教育して
正しい価値観・道徳を教えなくてはならないのです。
ですから
子供に自分たちを解読されたら
これはうまくいかないのです。
だからといって自分の頭がまったく混乱して
いい加減な状態だったらそれもまたできないし
そこらへんで我々が勉強しなくちゃいけないことが
いっぱいあるのです。
だいたいこの
子育てに失敗している
両親というのはみんな
まあ、子供になめられているだけなのです。
子供に読まれているのです。
どのように読まれているのかというと
親が子供を叱る場合は
子供は暗記しているのですね。
どんな言葉で叱るのかを。
何の意味もないんです。それだったら。
（子供が）暗記していることを親が言っているだけなのだから。
だから、本当は情けないのは我々大人なのです。
ですからひとつ申し上げたいのは
皆さまにはそういった幼い子供はいないかもしれませんが
我々より経験が少ない
まだまだ人生それほど生きていない人々というのは
大人に対しては大変な宿題なのです。
我々は瞬間、瞬間
頭を働かせて新しい智慧を
作り出さなければ
この世の中はうまくいかないのです。
これ会社にしても同じことなのですよ。
会社には上司がいて部下がいるのです。
部下は当然年下なのです。
経験も浅いのですよ。
それで、決まったパターンで
決まった文句で
決まったやり方で
朝から晩までしゃべていると
全然効率があがるどころか自分がなめられているだけなのです。
ですから、私たちの話を
聞いている側が
今日は何の話でしょうか？と
「真剣に聞かなきゃ！」という
状態を作らなくてはならない。
そういうことなんです。
まあ私は座ってしゃべると落ち着いてしまいますから
話がなかなかむずかしくなるかもしれません。
いわゆるチャレンジなんですね。
私個人のことでいえば
大人に説法することは僕にとっては
なんともない、ものすごく簡単で、つまらないものなのです。
なにもチャレンジがないんですよ。
なにか質問があったとしても
その人が質問する前に何を質問するかわかってしまうので。
「ちょっと相談したいのですけど・・・」といっても
こっちはもうとっくにわかっているのです。
どういう相談かと。
それぐらいもう見えているのです。
経験ある大人の心というのは。
でも子供の場合は全くちがうのです。
子供が質問をすると私は
ものすごく真剣に集中して聞くのです。
なにを聞かれるかわからないのだから。
それで質問に
返事できるかどうか、それがまた大変なんですよ。
かなり神経をつかうのです。
ですから、もう
すごく自分に対しても
一時間話し終わったら
今日はよくがんばりましたと
よく無事に征服しましたと。
なにかすごい国際試合にでたような感じなのです。
そこは私たちもやっぱり
子供がいなくても会社に勤めている場合は部下がいるんだから
あるいは社会のなかで必ず年下のひとがいるのだから
これはチャレンジだとおもってください。
子供が読めるような
事前に解読されるようなことをいっても
なんのEffect(影響）もないんだと。
それは我々にとっても同じなのです。
もし私が今日何を話すか皆様方が知っていたならば
全然面白くないでしょう？
もし、あのーなんといいますか・・・
もし予測できたならば
今日は仏教の話だからお釈迦様とか
いろいろ仏教でこういう
こういうお経がありますとか、仮に学者であっても
「あ、そういう内容だろう」とわかったら面白くないのです。
心に入らないのです。
ですからだいたい
どんなテーマであろうが、ビックリすることを
いくらでも僕にはいえますけれども
あまり日本でビックリすることを言うと
皆ビックリしすぎて混乱するのですね。
それは私はどうかなと思いますね。
ということは皆さんは小さい時から
決まったパターンで
教えられていて
全部規則のなかで決まっているのですね。
まっすぐ行って、右に曲がって、またいって、信号にきたら左に曲がってとかね
そうだから、ちょっと違うことを言ったら
なんか驚いたり
理解しなかったりするし
私も日本の社会のことを知りませんし
皆様の意見はよく聞くのです。
何をしゃべったらいいのか
どういう風にしゃべったらいいのですかとか
どういうことを皆さま聞きたがっているのですかとか
そこで
ああだ、こうだとか私に言うのです。
いうときは私は本当は
よく聞く人なんですけど、しゃべるよりは・・・。
で、聞いているとみんな同じパターンで同じことをいっているのではないかと。
これは仏教にならないのだと。
革命的で刺激的で
これからどうなるかとワクワクしている状態でなければ、心の中も
仏教的にはならないのですね。
たまにあの人々は
我々の考え方だとこうなります、ああなりますと
自分の知っている仏教は
こういうことです。
ですから、「そういう風にしゃべってください」と。
で私は「はいわかりました」といって
その講演では徹底的に壊すのです。
概念やら考え方、価値観などを
爆弾みたいな話をして
そこで「あ、この坊主の話はあまりよくないのだ」と。
「何を言っているのかわからないのだ」と。
で、僕は怒られるのですね。「やりました」と自分が今日は。
（そういわれたものの）一人で勝手に喜んでいるのですね。
そこで言いたいポイントは
そういう決まっているパターンとかね
決まり文句とか、何もEffect（影響）がないのですよ。
例えば日本の伝統的な仏教にしても
同じことだから
決まってることを決まってるしきたり
決まっている教え
まあちょっと自分で考えて
なにかちょっと刺激的なことを現代人にいわなければ
みんな逃げてしまうのですね。
それはまあこのお寺は違いますけど
我々はあちこち追い出されるのだけれども
「じゃあ、まあ、勝手にしゃべってください」と。
大変親切に
助けていただいていますからね
ですから、私も大変自由に
たまに過激なことをいうかもしれません
そういう風なことがあると
人間がやっぱり興味があって勉強するのです。
そこでポイント！
人間というのはいつでも変化するものなのです。
我々は昔から
社会をそのまま守った
あほ・バカではないのです。
システムやらしきたりやら生き方やら
なんだかんだ大事に守ろうと
と、偉そうに言うのだけども
大事に守ったらどうなるんですか！？
もし日本人が自分の文化・自分の価値判断
考え方
すごい大事に、丁寧に守っていて
だからいまだに「奈良時代」なんですよ。
全然変化していないんですよ
でも、もし私が何か（その人たちに）いったならば
「あなたたちは自分たちの文化を壊しているのだ」といったら怒られるのですよ。
なんで怒られるのかわからない。本当に壊しているのだから。
この教育のおかしいところはそういうところなのです。
我々が子供やら次の世代を教育すると
まあ、いままでこの店は
十七代までこのように伝わってきたのだから
その教訓やらしきたりやら全部守りなさいと。
学校でもこういうことをちゃんと守りなさいと。
文化やら価値観やら全部守りなさいとか
偉そうに口で言うのだけども
それはもう「化石論」なんですね。
「化石になりなさい」ということなんですよ。
化石になってどうするんですかね？
ただ、埃を拭いて
もうそのまま置いておくと
だから教育の世界で
色々失敗があるのですよ。
例えば子供は
過激な、いい加減な、自分勝手な、好き勝手なことをやると
先生は三倍やると、それより
子供たちは呆れちゃうんです。
この先生にはなかなか歯が立ちませんと。
社会というのは変わるものだから
我々は、私も老人だから
こちらにも私と同じ年の方々がいらっしゃるのだから
我々はやっぱり
落ち着きたいんですよ。
あんまり、今更変化はもうちょっと
肌にあわないのです。
でも、私が変化しないからと言って
私の次に世代にもあなたもおとなしくしなさいというのは
大変間違っている教えなのです。
そうじゃなくて「かってにしなさい」と。
私は自分の弟子たちにそういったんですね。
いろいろしきたりを教えるのだけどもどうもきいてくれない。
破っちゃうんです。
そこで決めたんです。
あなた方は勝手にしなさい。
どうなろうが私は見ようともしないのだと。
理由も教えてあげるんですね。
私はもう年だから
あなたがたよりずいぶん先に死んでしまう。
それからの世界はあなた方の世界なのだと。
その世界がどんな世界であろうが
関係ないのだと。
勝手にしなさいと。
それを怒って言うのではなくて、
すごく明るい心で
にこにことじゃあ勝手にしなさいと。
そういわれたらその弟子たちは
その日からすごい責任感を感じ始めたのです。
やっぱりふざけていてはだめだと
いちいち守ってくれませんと。
いちいちおっしゃってくれません。
自分で判断しなければいけないのだと。
で、なんとかわかってきて
落ち着いてちゃんと自分で判断し、行動するようになってきたのです。
ですから
一応そういうことを覚えておきましょう。
世の中は変化する。
私たちの小さい時の社会は
今はない。
今の社会はこれからもない。
教育の世界で必要なのは
変わる社会を作る
能力がある人材なのです。
inspirationのある人々なのです。
物事を新しく考える人々なのです。
ですから、へんてこりんな人が一番いいのです。わかりやすくいえば。
わがままで、好き勝手やって
何か言ったら
とんでもないことを言い返すとかね。だいたい子供の中でそういう人々がいるのです。
「これはこういう風にやりなさい」といったら
そうではなくて全く違う風にやってしまう。
もっとわかりやすくいえば
いかにして親に逆らうのかと。
そればっかり考えている子供たちがいるのです。
あれはすごく才能があるんです。
正しく育てれば
この世の中のためになるのです。
一番悪いのは親が言うことを
なんでもかんでもおとなしくきく子なんです。
それは心配したほうがいいのです。
早死にするんだと
この社会で
生きていられないのだと。
ですから英語でいう"Obedience"
「よく聞く（従順）」
たいへんいい道徳だといっていますけど
あまりにも（それほど）
いいことではないのです。
なぜならば大人がいうことを完全に聞く
人がいるならば
完璧にバカなんです。
自分で何も判断しませんから
大人が消えちゃったらどうするんですかね。
その人々は。
何もできないでしょうに。
会社のサラリーマンにはなるんだけど
課長にはならないんですよ。
ですから、仏教からいうならば
サラリーマン教育をやめてほしい。
課長、社長をつくる教育をしてほしいということなんです。
それすごい大変ですけどね。
いうこと聞かない子供がいると
なかなか親は大変です。
大変ということが一番いいのです。
親がバカにならないのだから。
親も
毎日頭を
困らせて考えなくちゃいけないのだから
そういうことなんですね。
仏教の立場から説明すると
そういうことなんです。
お釈迦様は結局同じ社会ずっと
あってほしい（つづいてほしい）とおもっていないのです。
とにかくお釈迦様はこうおっしゃったんだから
仏教は真理の教えであると。
過去も現在も未来もこの真理はかわりませんと。
ですから時間・・・
時代遅れになる教えではないのだと。
真理ですから。変わるはずがないのです。
それでもその仏教はあまり長生きはしません。
真実だからこの社会で残るだろうとはいってないのです。
まあ
あまり
長生きはしませんと
消えます。
何で消えるかというと社会が変わりますから
それをよく知っていたのです。
どんどんかわっていくものだと。
だからいい方向に変えていく、悪い方向に変えていく
それはわかるものではないし
必ずしもいい方向に変わるわけでもないのです。
悪い方向にもいってしまうし。
そういうことはストップすることはできないのです。
少々できるのは
次の世代だけ
いくらかいい方向へ
変えるようにちょっと手を打っておくだけ。
それで皆さまにそういう話は全然役に立ちませんから
一応このこういう概念が仏教に在りますということはね
そういうすごく刺激的な
教えがあったならば
この日本の現代の若者は悪い方向にはいかないのですよ。
このへんな社会に大変危険な教えのグループとかあるのだけども
そういうところにはいって
親不孝にすることはしませんね。
すでにうちの中が戦争だから
うちのなかでも子供は一生懸命に頑張らなくてはならない
状態をつくっていると。
まったく反社会的なところに入って
頑張ってみようとは思わないのです。
だから、新しいことをしなければ心の中に刺激がないのです。
我々の社会は生ぬるい
決まっていて、すべてのものが決まっているのだから
もうチャレンジが無い
だから
現代
若者たちが
ほとんどの人々が
若者といえないほど力が無い
力がある人々はなにかとんでもないことに
はしっていってしまう。
そういう風な残念な現象がいくらかある。全部ではないのだけども。
でまあ、その話はそこでおいておいて
今日は他のことをいいたい。
私たちは子供を教育するのではなくて
我々はもう
我々には一杯
子供から勉強することがあるのです。
ですから我々が自分の勉強をしていますよ。
子供にああだこうだとえらそうに
指導したり命令したり
教えたりするということより
限りない知識
智慧
子供から得られるのです。
その方法を勉強したほうがいいんじゃないかなと。
いろんなことを勉強させてくれる。
どういう勉強ができますかね。
子供から
もうひとつ。我々は子供から勉強する。
子供が先生だとおもって
私たちが生徒になって
まずいいポイントがあるんですね。
我々はいつでも精神的に
健康的になるのです。肉体的にも。
若返るのです。
体が年取ってしまっても、心が年をとると困るのです。
いつでも若い時とおなじ
すごくやる気があって
元気で活動することができるのですよ。子供から勉強するのならば。
ですから大変役に立つのです。
それを覚えておいてください。
子供から何を勉強できますかね？
ポイント１はこれなんです。
子供は大体
読めないのですよ。
大人に。
何をするかわからないのですね。
例えばお部屋でもいいし、部屋にちょっといれてみてください。
部屋に入れて十分、十五分たったら
なにをするかわかりますか。
我々大人は部屋の中に三十分いたら
本でも読んでしまうのです。
それか寝てしまう。もうわかるのですよ。
では子供２－３人部屋に入れて
ドア締めてみてください。
何するかわからないのです。
その
読めないところ
我々の勉強になるのです。
で、子供は決して悪いことをするのではないのです。
子供のポイントは
部屋にはいったのだから
大人に怒られたのだから
それで我々はどうすれば面白いかと
我々にとってどうすればすごく気持ちよく
たのしく
遊べるかと。もううるさいんだから部屋にいれたんだけど
でも結局親に逆らっているのですね。
大人に。
我々どうすれば自分に対して面白いか
快感を得られるかと
それをすぐ発見するのです。
いわゆるどう生きるべきかと
この三十分で。
その十分でも。
どういれば面白いかと
それは大人が忘れているのです。
子供は忘れてないんです。
ですから子供のやり方を見ていると
なるほど、と勉強になるのですよ。
たとえば小学生の子供達とかね、電車なんかで
３－４人のグループでいくんだけど。
みてください。
電車で十分いる場合は十種類の遊びをやっているのです。
一分ごとにかわっちゃうんです。
次にどんな遊びをするか想像ができない。
まあなにか違うことをやるのです。
中学生も高校生もそれなりにまあ
高校生になると大変疲れているのだけれども
なにをするかわからない。
でも結局本人が自分たちで楽しくあそんでいるんです。
で、そこは子供は
遊ぶことで成長するんだから
それは子供の生き方なんです。
我々には例えば日曜日と土曜日と連続で
連休だったらじゃあどうしようかとわからなくなってしまうのです。
我々大人が
発明的なこころ、新しいことを発見するこころを
失っているのです。
いわゆる型がきまっているのです。
だから
人生は苦しいんです。
つまらないのです。大人にとっては。
だから仏教でもきくのです。
仏教でも聞けば幸福になるのではないかと。
私の話を聞いたとしても
Vipassana修行したとしても
脳細胞が元気でなければなにも効果がないのです。
とにかく私は刺激を与えようとおもっていますが
反応する人ははやく
反応してそれなりの幸福を得られるのですね。
あーつまらない、なにかないのですかという感じで
じゃあ仏教でも勉強しましょうかと
あんまり役に立ちませんね。
ですからいくら年をとっても
１００歳になっても
頭だけは元気で
若くておいておかなければ
もう一生暗いんです。人生は。
そこは我々はこの
子供から勉強すべきポイントなんです。
なにか新しいものにチャレンジしなければならない。
そこでこの
ポイント二つあります。考えなくてはならないポイントが。
だいたい、じゃあ何かしようと思っている
元気なおじいちゃん、おばあちゃんが日本には
大勢いるんですよ。
どういうことをやっていますかというと９０歳になって
社交ダンス勉強しようと
習おうと。
いってまあ、九十歳でからだ動くわけでもないんです。
それで骨を折ったりして
もう大変なことになるんです。
おじいちゃんもおじいちゃんたちで自転車にのるはオートバイに乗るは。
八十歳、九十歳になったところで
そういうことをやっている元気な方々がいますよ。ある面ですごくかわいいのだけれども
あるいはゲートボールですね。
ある日、国立のほうで朝歩いていると
おじいちゃんたちがみんなあつまって
一生懸命元気にゲートボールをやっているのですね。
それで日本の社会はそれをほめるかもしれません。
ああ、やっぱり日本の年取っている方々は大変健康的で元気で
いわゆる、そういう
文化的な活動をやっているのだと
私はそういう元気でゲートボールやっているおじいさん、おばあさんをみて
「あ、つまらない人生だな」と。思ったんです。
これではつまらないのだと。
これでは生きる楽しみが無くなってしまうのだと。
なぜかというと、頭はもう型が決まっているのです。
年取ったんだからゲートボールと。
なんでフットボールなんかをやらないのですかね。
なんで年取ったらゲートボールやってるんですかね。
あれ、私にはわかりません。
足が動かなければ杖でも持ってければいいんだから。
これはわたしの足だよと。
だから何か新しいことを考えることができない。
それはひとつポイントで
でも、考えてみてください。年取ったら
おばあちゃまたちがそれなりの掃除やら
あるいは和歌ですか、
歌会とか
あるいは踊りをならう
おじいちゃんたちがゲートボールとか
あれでおもしろいんですかね。つまらないと思いますよ。
で、我々に勉強するべきものはいっぱいあるんですよ。
死ぬまで勉強すべきものは
すごくあるんです。
それを忘れているのです。
勉強というものは大学卒業したら終わりだとおもっているのです。
あるいは会社で仕事に必要な勉強してそれで終わりと。
一人も人生に必要なことは勉強していないのです。
生きるために必要なことは勉強していないのです。
学校に行ったらつまらないことしか勉強しないでしょうに。
数学やら
何の役にも立たない歴史やら
社会学やら、全然実行しない社会学とかね。
科学とか。
一人も科学者にならないのに科学を勉強したりとか。
仕事に行ったらそれは全然役に立ちませんし。
大学で一生懸命勉強するんだけど会社に行ったらまた全部勉強やり直しですから。
ですから
どこかがおかしいんですよ。
別に算数を勉強してはいけないということではなくて
それは子供たちが勉強するのであって
学校卒業するために
大学にいったら大学で精一杯研究するのであって
会社に行ったら会社で精一杯勉強するんであって
でもそれは
人生のほんのかすかな一部だけなのです。
我々は生まれてから
死ぬまで
いやでも生きてるんですよ。
死んでからはわかりませんが。
ですからこの
生まれた瞬間から死ぬまで生きてるんだから
生きてることを勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね。
どう生きるべきかと
どう生きていければ
どう生きていれば
充実感・満足感・幸福感を味わえるのか
どう生きていけば
つまらない、むなしいとならないんですかと。
苦しみが消えるんですかと
我々の
体から子供のように
子供はエネルギーいっぱい、体からエネルギーはでていっちゃいますから。
この部屋に大人の方々がここまでいたとしても
なんとなく寂しいんだけど
子供二人いれてみてください。
この建物全体がうるさくなってしまいますから
あの、生のエネルギーで。
なんで私たちにそれができないのですか。
どこでそれは死んでしまったんですかね？
ですからおじいちゃんたちが
このあいだゲートボールをやっているのをみて
感じたのは
やっぱりつまらない人生だと
年取ったらやることないのだと
だから、おじいちゃんかたが集まって
なんとかゲートボールをしている。
もっと意味があるものはないのですかと。
そこは我々
といったっても、これはやっぱり
まあ、仏教の仕事でもあると思いますよ。
人間になにか教えてあげなくちゃいけない。
それは何かというと「生きる方法」なんです。
エネルギーが消えない方法なんです。
子供が持ってるエネルギーが。
私は今日そういうことを教えないでただ
驚かせて話を終わりにしようとおもっていますけどね。
皆を混乱させて
頭がこんがらがっちゃって、そんな状態で今日の話は終了しましたと
いうことで一応決めてはありましたけど
「何もつかめるポイントは今日はいいません」と。
なぜならば
刺激なんです。必要なのは。
人生はクイズでなければいけません。
私がクイズを出して、ひとつのクイズを出して
答えをいいますよと。それはおもしろくないでしょう。
たとえばなにかものすごいテスト問題があって
答えはこれですけど、じゃああなた答えてくださいといっても
何にもクイズにならないのだから
やっぱり人生は
どうしても解きがたいクイズであってほしいのです。
一つ解くと次の問題が出る。
それを何とかするとまた次の問題がでてくる。
きりがなく
問題が出てくる
それが人生なんです。
それをなんで我々は
消すんですかと。
なんで一定のパターンを決めて、パターンのなかで
Trackを決めて
決めて
そのなかでずーっと
回っているんです。だから年取ったらゲートボールと決まっているんです。
別にやってはいけないわけではないのですよ。
もし皆様がやっているのであれば
どうぞ、それは元気で体に健康にいいのだからやってください。
それに文句を言っているわけではなく
なにか違うものを
言いたがっているのです。
まあ、答えとしていうならば
どう生きるべきかと、生きることを勉強する
ことなんですね。
子供は結構しってるんですよ。生きる方法というのは。
たとえば、小さな子供になにか
ほしがっているものをあげないでみてください。
あげませんと。
どっちが負けるんですか。
自分にはおぼえがあるでしょうね。子供が小さいとき
なんとかほしいと。
だめ、いけませんとお母さんがいうでしょう。
それで負けるのは誰ですか。
９９％お母さんがまけるでしょう。
お父さんが負けるでしょう。
あれなんですかね。
たとえば何か食べたいという。
お母さんは知っているのです。これは体に悪いものだと、
ダメと言っても結局
大人のほうが負けるのです。
子供というのは不思議に
自分の目的を達成する
技を知っているのです。
なにか言葉にならない何かをもっているのです。
それは死ぬまであってほしいのですよ。
たとえば皆様方同じ技を私に掛けると
私のほうの話の内容がすぐ変わるのです。
例えば、自分が何か知りたいことがあるならば
私が勝手に教えてあげるわけではないのです。
絞らなくてはならない。
それが必要なんです。
子供はそれをしっていて大人は忘れている
それは一つのポイントです。
この生きる術
生きる技
一応子供の
世界から勉強して
我々も通用すると我々も子供の用に
元気で生きていられる
ちょっとだけ答えをいいますけど
例えばスポーツしたり
運動したり
それの刺激で生きているということは
あんまりくだらないんです。
それは若者がやっていることなのです。
例えば年とっても
音楽にふけっているんだと。
そんなことは二十歳で卒業してほしいんですよ。
自分の年と同時に
もっと高度なもの
もっと高度なものにいかなくちゃいけない。
盆栽いじったりするだけではなくて
ですから私たちの
勉強する
人生という学校は
一年毎に新しい何かがなければなりません。
学校に行ったらそうでしょうに。
大学に行ったら一年生ではこれ、二年生ではこれと、三年目ではこれ、四年目ではこれで卒業ときまっているのだから。
一年目の項目・単位を
二年目、三年目、四年目と同じことをやっていたら卒業できないでしょうに。
ですから
去年はこれやったんだから
今年もこれということではなくて
毎年なにか新しい
ものにチャレンジすることが必要なのです。毎日。
僕はわかりやすく言うのは
自分にもいってほしいことなんですけど
昨日より今日は充実に
何か新しい違うものをするという決まりなんです。
私は大体怠け者だから、じゃあ明日しますとおもいますけどね。
「今日よりは明日頑張ります」
その「明日頑張る」というのはとんでもないんです。それは怠け。
やらないんです。
明日やりますと。
じゃあ今日はのんびりしますとなりますからね。
皆さまもできれば
昨日よりなにか新しいものを
今日は得ようと
じゃあ、得る新しいものはなんですかね。
これは財産とかそんなものではないんです。
それも中年で終わってほしいんです。
名誉とかね。
例えば、美容・美しさとかね。
そういうものは卒業してほしい。
なにか違うところでなにか見つかる。
価値観、高度な価値観を得て
努力すれば
よろしいんじゃないかなと。
一つこの子供から勉強しましょうといったんだから
一応答えをださなきゃ
皆さま困りますから
ひとつ、ふたつくらい答えだします。
子供は生きてるときは
よく見えることは
どんなつまらないものであろうが遊びにしてしまうのですね。
遊びに回しちゃうのです。
あるいは、なにか楽しくなければ何もやらないのです。
ですから我々子供を教えるときでも
結構この遊びを中心に教える場合もあるし
そこで我々は何を勉強しますかというと
我々大人になったら
人生が楽しくなくなっちゃって暗くなるんです。
何で暗くなるんですかね。
子供には例えば
電車にいるとき
相手をぶん殴ったりとかね
もう何とかして遊んでいるんですね。
つり革にぶら下がって
なんとか遊んでいるのです。
結構楽しんでいるんですね。
私たちに迷惑ということはおいといて
本人にとっては楽しいんだから
大人になるとなんでそれが消えますかね。
そこにポイントがあるんです。
大人になると我々は人生わすれちゃって
幸福・楽しさというのは「今あるもの」ではなくて
「これからのもの」だと思っちゃうんです。
「よし、これから幸福になるぞと」
「これから」というのは「いまは不幸でいい」ということなんです。
ですから、大人は電車にいるとつまらない
おとなにとっては。
「まだまだ、一時間かかりますか」と。
子供のはそうではない。
ですからこの幸福というものは
今！得なくてはいけないのです。
今！楽しくなければ
今！充実感がなければ
いけないのです。
大体仏教の世界で
今！という一言にものすごく重点を置いているのは
そういうことなんです。
今！上手に生きていられる人は
もう、ずっと上手に生きていられるんです。
どこにあるか私にはわかりませんが
皆様発見して私に教えてほしいことがあるんです。
我々はいつ
「今！楽しめる。」
これを忘れたんですかね
皆さまも同じことですから
小さい頃は楽しかったでしょうに。
どこかで
外れちゃったんです
さきだと思っちゃうんです。
例えば若い女の子だったら
「じゃあ、結婚してから幸せになりますよ」とか。
とんでもない男と結婚したらどうするんですかね。
ですから、今、幸福感を
得られなくては、決めなくては
体験しなくては
もう大変なんです。
この忘れたのはどこで忘れたんですかね。
もう一つ注意ポイントがあります。
子供はなにかふざけてつり革に
ぶら下がったりとかあちこちきゃーきゃー
泣いたり、遊んだり
そういうくだらないことで楽しみますけど
私は皆様方にも同じこと
してくださいとは言ってないのですよ。
いい大人がお互いに指でつつきあって
遊んでいたらそれはもう病気ですから。
そういうことを言ってるわけではないのです。
毎日勉強だから毎日成長しなければならないのだから。
大人にもそれなりのなにかがあるはずなのです。
例えば、私は大体
大体この
どこかへ誰かと一緒にいくときは
つまらないと思った瞬間に
すぐ自分でなにかゲームを考えるのです。
いくらか言語学的な能力がある
人だったら
目に入る広告やら
いろんなものがいっぱいあるのですね。
色々カラクリするんです。瞬間に。
よく智慧をつかうんですね。
こういう意味で書いていますけど、これをこうしたら
全く違う意味になりますよと。
そういうことで相手にいろんなことをいって
質問出したりする。
相手と一緒にいる人も
結構智慧がなければ
瞬間的に考えることができなければ
自分に返事することはできない。
向こうが返事することができなかったら「あんたは新しいことを考えていないのだ」と。
「こういうことだ」と。自分ではいっている。
その瞬間に、また私は新しいことを考えようとしているのです。
ですから、大人になるとそれなりの
大人の
なにか楽しみがあるはずなのです。
仏教を勉強することも同じことで
普通の社会で普通仕事をしていて
日常の給料のために頑張っていたんだけど
ここでは
善とはなんであろうか？　心とはなんであろうか？
存在とはなんであろうか？　我々はなんで生きているのでしょうか？　とか。
とてつもない高度なものを
探検しようとする
それも大変な大人の
勉強でもあるし、意味のある仕事なのです。
ですから、ゲートボールよりは
心の真理を
探したほうがいいと思います。
年取ってくると
インドの社会では一応全部決まっているのです。
ヒンドゥー教で仏教ではないんだけど
若いときは
欲を捨てて
徹底的に勉強しなさい
小さい時から
勉強終ったら
①ブラフマチャーリーというんです。
ブラフマチャーリーというのは出家というのとおなじなんですね。
異性を全く気にしてはいけないのです。
勉強して全部おわったところで
仕事をして結婚して
社会人として活動する
②グリハスタというのですね。二番目は。
それで、子供がいくらか大きくなって
独立してきたなと思ったら
全財産子供に全部あげて
自分は引退する。
これを③ヴァーナプラスタとサンスクリット語でいうのです。
いわゆる引退する。
引退してただ黙っているわけではなくて
それから真理を
求めて勉強する
宗教を勉強する
いくらか元気ですから
子供たちに自分を養ってもらいますから
勉強をする。
それ終ったらもう年取っているのですね。
年取ったら④サンニャーシという。
どこにもとどまることなく
あっちこっち歩く。
歩いていろんな仙人たちにあったり
いろんなところに修行してみたり
頑張ってる
で、どこかで死んでしまう。
自分の人生がどうなるかは決まってない。
それは仏教ではないんです。まあ、一応書きますが
サンスクリット語で
Uを書きたいのだけど本当は
Rの下に点をいれるんですね。
文学的・学問的な符号としては
動詞は要りません
なぜならばゲハストとよむのです。
我々はゲハストと読むのです。ですから、どうしよう・・・
困ってますけどここは。
そういう ヒンドゥー教で
四つの生き方
若い時から死ぬまで勉強なんですよ。
こんなに人生が苦しいとか
あーこまったとか
精神的に参ったとか
そんな暇がないのです。
死ぬ瞬間まで頑張っている
でも
我々現代人みたいに
欲のために儲かるために
頑張っているわけではないのです。
高度なもののために。
①ブラフマチャーリーというのは青年の時。
青年のときは
教育
②グリハスタというのは妻帯して
普通の社会人として活動する
結婚して子供育てて
社会人として活動する
③ヴァーナプラスタというのは、
真理を
勉強する時期。
④サンニャーシというのは
修行の時期なんですけど
遊行ともかくし
勉強した心理をいろんなところにいって
実践してみる。
この四つに残念ながら仏教は反対なんです。
仏教はインドで
パターン決まってるのだからつまらなかったのです。
決まってるんだからね。子供の時は勉強するとか
若いときは結婚して仕事をするとか
お釈迦様にとっては
それはつまらなかったんですね。若い時に逃げちゃったんだから。
ですからこれはヒンドゥー教・インドの教えです。
仏教の教えではない。
仏教が何で反対しますかというと
途中で人が死ぬかもしれませんしね。
勉強しているところで死ぬかもしれませんし。
仕事している途中でもね
人生が終わるかもしれません。
真理を知る時間がなくなってしまうのです。
あの世の幸福を作る時間が消えちゃうのです。
例えば修行をするため８０歳になるまで待ってましたと。
８０歳になったところで
例えば、もし
脳細胞がやられて
マヒ状態になったとか
体が全く動かないとかいろいろありますから人の体は。
そうすると修行どころではないのです。
実践できないのですね。
あるいは耳がすごく遠くなったと
人の話は
理解できない。
ですから、こんなシステム決めたら
また、これもよくないと、仏教はこれも
壊しちゃうんですけどね。
これからわかるポイントは、やっぱり死ぬまで
チャレンジして生きていかなくてはいけないということなのです。
それが我々に
子供から勉強できることです。
ですから皆様方は今日はこういう
大人の世界にはいって
大人がするべきこと
あるいはいつでも人間として
するべきことをなさっているのですね。
真理、
道徳というものを勉強するということはね。
これからも頑張ってべんきょうしてみてください。
心という
今日の話の中で
もしかして、テーマで子供の心とかという言葉があったかもしれません。
一つのポイントだけを申し上げたいのです。
こころというポイント。
子供の心という言葉を使いますかね？日本では。
今日覚えておいてください。子供の心というのは
ないのです。
赤ちゃんの心
大人の心とか、そういうのはないんです。
心には赤ちゃんも老人もないのです。
心にとっては年は関係ない。
体にはあるんです。
それを忘れがちなんです。
皆さま自分の心に聞いてみてください。
自分の年と自分の心の状態
精神状態どうですかと。
例えば、六十歳の方は
自分の心の中でも本当に六十歳だと思っていますか。
あるいは三十代のかたは
自分の心の中で本当に三十代だと思っていらっしゃいますか？
それはないと思います。
二十歳の方だってそうですよ。
私は二十歳だから大人ですよと思っていますか？
思ってない。
九十歳、百歳になっても
心に聞いてみてください。
テレビでよく出るきんさん・ぎんさんの顔を見てもね
心だけはすごい元気でしょうに
なにか若者みたいに
若い人みたいに会う人々に
ものすごくにこにこ笑って
いろいろ話をして「会いたかったよ」とかなんとかいって
そういうテレビのキャラクターになっても
なんの意味もないのだけどね。でも
やっぱり、心は元気なんですね。若いんですよ。
ですから、そこは真理であって、心は年取らない。
いわゆる年という概念がない。
それで、私たちはよく失敗するのは
赤ちゃんは赤ちゃんだと思っちゃうんです。
何も知らない赤ちゃんだ、かわいいかわいいと。
あれで大失敗するんですよ。
赤ちゃんは全然自分を赤ちゃんだと思ってないんですよ。
すごく怒っているんです。あかちゃんは。
自分が自由に活動・行動したいのだけど
手も足も動かない。
だから泣くのですよ。
おなかがすいたらまあ
食べ物はちゃんと誰かが作って
食べさせなければ自分で食べられない。
それを言葉ではなくてものすごく感じるのです。
いやでしようがないんです。
かなりストレスたまってますよ。お母さんだけじゃなくて子供にも。
そこは我々忘れているのですね。
自分たちが一生懸命、頑張って面倒みているのだから
赤ちゃんが幸福だと思ってるだけで
あれは大変なストレスの塊なのです。
心は
年取ることもないし、ではなくて
心には年の概念がない。
ですからこの、これから
子供作ろうと思ってる方がいらっしゃるならば
やっぱり自分にはね
そういう子供が家に現れたとしたら
それはもう
赤ちゃんではないのだと
と、思ってほしいのです。
普通の生命であって
普通の正真正銘の人間であると。
自分と同じ
独立心が強い
いろいろいちいち言われたくない
相手にいじめられたくない
断固たる人間であるということだけは
忘れてほしくない。
そこらへんで我々は赤ちゃん見たらかわいいんだからね
かわいいかわいいという感情にもう
負けて
子供をいじめるのです。
かわいいかわいいではなくて
たいへんな大事なポイントで
自分たちがある人間を育ててあげているだけなんですね。
それを覚えておいてください。
心の問題として
我々よりは精神的な問題がいっぱい
赤ちゃんの時から子供にあるのです。なぜかというと
自分が感覚としては
普通の生命として大人なんですけど
しゃべれない
歩けない
感情を表すことができない
すごく不自由を感じるんです
それは仏教の世界の話だから医学とは違うのです。
脳が発達していないとか
言葉とかそんなことは知らなくても
感じとしてはあるんです。Vipassana瞑想でもして
できれば自分の過去を思い出してみてください。
たまに才能ある人は
自分の赤ちゃんの時まで思い出せるかもしれません。
その時はいかに不自由でしたかと。
自分の意見が社会に通らなくて
嫌な思いをしたかということを思い出すはずなんです。
言葉で考えることをちょっとやめて
Vipassanaでも実践して
最悪なんですよ。赤ちゃんの時期というのは
大人から見れば赤ちゃんはいいですねとか
おもうかもしれませんが。
一番いいのは人間としては今の年なんです。
中年の時なんです。
いくらか自分の意見が通りますから。
我々から見れば若者は幸福だなあと思うかもしれませんが
若者もすごく苦しいんですよ
大人にいつでも遠慮しなくてはいけないのですから
まあ、一応五十代くらいになるといくらか
ほんのつかの間なんですけど、
自分の意思が通ります。
それまで全部不自由なんです。
それから年取るでしょう
体が不自由になってしまうでしょう。
そこで一番、最近もあるひとがいいましたけど、
自分のお母さんがねものすごくいうことをきかないのだと
もういつもケンカばっかりですよと。
あーだ、こーだとどうすればいいんですかと。
孫たちに叱るのだそうですし
いつでも面倒見ている息子が
一緒に面倒見ているのだけども
もうひとり上の息子がいて
お母さんがその人のことばかりかわいがっているんだと
そこに行きたがっているのだと。
この人には
面白くないのですね。
自分のうちにいるんだから
もし
兄のほうにいくならば
大変気持ちよく向こうに行って
日帰りで帰るんだと。
兄弟のあれでまあ
どうすればいいんですかと。
私は「その場合はあなたに何を言っても意味がない」のだが
わたしも時間がないんだからといって
ちょっと教えてあげましたけど、やっぱり年取ってくると
息子さんにいってあげたんですね
自分の先が見えているんだと
もうそろそろ死にますから
特に仏教の世界だから
もう死ということは覚悟の上だから
日本みたいに「死にませんよ」と思って
生活するわけではないのだから。（日本では）癌になったって告知しないんだから。
そういう嘘の世界ではないのだから
いつでも死にますよということはもう
刻み込まれているし
ですから、当然年取ったら自分の死ということはもう
じりじりとしっているんです。
そこで計算するんですよ
私はもうあともしかすると半年とか
一か月間とか
で、半年間しかいないんだから
お前が私のことをもう少し親切にしたらどうですかと
という風におもっちゃうんです。
そこでやっぱりこの
いろいろややこしくなっちゃうんです。
自分が半年間で
全く消えてしまうのだから
もうちょっと親切にしてくれてもいいのではないかと
紅茶をあげても「これは熱すぎですよ」とか
「これは冷めているではないか」と
なんとか文句をいうのです。
ご飯を作ったら「ごはんが固い。食べられません。」
次の日は一生懸命柔らかくしてあげる
「こんなものは食べられない。柔らかすぎる」と。
だからもう子供たちが
もうやりきれませんと。このお母さんとは。
なんで年取るとわがままになるんですか
ポイントはそこじゃないんです。
僕はそれを教えてあげたんです。
お母さんはもうそろそろなくなるんだから
あなたがたはもうちょっと親切な心で
接してほしいのだと。
別に
ご飯が固くても柔らかくても
そんな問題ではないのだと。
といって、いろいろ
工夫を教えてあげたんですね。
うまく、お母さんとつきあう方法を
こういうことをしてあげてください。と。
まあ私のお寺の大長老が無くなったときも
同じことでしたけど
やっぱり三か月間
長老は自分が亡くなることは結構前から
知っていたのだけれども
私たちはもう
二十歳くらいで
別に人が亡くなるということ
を思わない。
やっぱり、えらいわがままですね。
わがままですけどわたしはものすごい年下だから将来大事だから
私のことはすごくかわいがっていたんですね。
私に対してはわがままではなかったんだけど
他の長老たちにとっては
いろんなことを言いたい放題。あれはいけません、これはいけません
そうじゃない、ああじゃない
皆もう呆れてしまってやりきれないんだと。付き合いきれないのだと。
といって、全部私に任せてしまったんですね。
私は全部、定期的に面倒見てあげたんだけど
私も長老が亡くなると思ってなかったんだけど
やはり自分から見れば年上のおじいさんだから
一緒にいるのは楽しいんですね
いろんなことを教えてくれりするし
いつでも優しいし。こちらが年下だから。
そこでお互いに愛情があって
面倒みてあげる
向こうも私といれば楽しいし
私も三か月間全然寝ないで
面倒見てあげたんだけど全然疲れてもない
その時によくわかったのは
年取ってくるとどれほど
大変かと。
だから不自由で不自由で。いままで
元気で生きてきた人がいきなり
不自由になったら、あの苦しみというのは並みのものではないのですよ。
例えば、自分で飲みたいのだけども
飲ませてもらわなければならない。あれってすごく気持ち悪いのですよ。
人に飲ませてもらう、食べさせてもらう
着替えさせられる
そういうことだから、そうならないように
今から元気でね心も健康的で元気で
おいておかなくちゃいけない。そこで言いたかったのは
心には年の概念がないこと。それを覚えておけば
皆さま方に子供の面倒がちゃんと見られるし
老人の面倒がちゃんと見られる
子供がないと老人もいない
ただ、人間がいてその中に
心が働いている
もうちょっとわかりやすくいいます
時間の関係で、具体的に
しゃべらないとそこらへんは難しい世界だからね
ちょっとややこしいのです。
一応こういうポイントだけ覚えておいてください。
いつかまた話す機会があったら
みなさんわかります。もし
年取ってる方々がいるならば
よく覚えておいてください。
体は年取っているんだけど心は
心には年の概念はないのだと。
まあ、時間は過ぎましたのですが。
もう一つ教育用ポイントをひとつ
ふたついっておわります。ポイントだけ。
じゃあ休憩はさみましょう。
じゃあこれから休憩で。
教育の
問題について
ポイント一つ申し上げたいのです。
世の中例えば日本のような
高い教育のある場合は
学校ではいろいろ知識やら
そういうものはきちんと正しく
教えてくれるんですね。
なんでもかんでも
そこらへんは問題ないんです。
教育というのは普通の世界の生きるためのことだから。
それはまあ方法もちゃんとあるし
道具もあるしちゃんとやっていますけど
人間として
なんかまあ
どこかで
出来上がっていないところがあるのです。
それから日本ではまあ学校で
道徳とかなんとかあるそうなんですけど
宗教は教えてませんし
日本で宗教を学校で教えるのは
もうややこしいんですね。
宗派は
数えきれないほどあるし
新しい宗教もあるし
宗教の時間があっても、どんな宗教を知るべきかと
わからなくなっちゃいますから
ですから、（宗教の時間が）ないのはある面では本当にいいかもしれません。
教えたとしてもこの宗教
日本の仏教の歴史とかね
いくらか歴史の中で教えてますけど
そんなものはあまり役に立たないのですね
奈良時代あーだこうだ、鎌倉時代あーだこーだとか
聖徳太子ああだこうだとか
こういう古い弘法大師がいましたとか
日蓮上人がいましたとか
親鸞上人がいましたとか
そんなことを勉強してもそれほど役に立たないのです。
人間としては
ですから教育のポイントはこれなんです。
この、しっかりした
人間として
どう生きるべきかと
それを小さい時から
心の中に入れておかなくてはいけない
どういうことかというと
道徳の基礎
土台
輪廻の土台
初めから子供達には「これはどうしようもない」と教えてあげなくてはいけない
教える方法は我々工夫してみなくてはいけない
それは今日ポイントだけは一応
教えてあげます。
この道徳とか倫理とか
宗教の立場からみるとややこしいのです
ですからそれは忘れましょう
例えばキリスト教の倫理は
仏教の倫理とちがうでしょう
日本の仏教をみても各宗派の倫理はまたいろいろ違いますから。
子供たちに何を教えればいいのかわからないのです。
ですからそこは別に教えなくてもいい。
大人になってからそれを勉強すればいい。
親鸞聖人が何をいった
日蓮が何をいったか
弘法大使がなにをおしえたか
それは大人になってからでいいんです。
でも、人間で生まれたならば
必ず
誰であろうが
知るべき基本的な倫理・道徳の土台があるのです。
それはお釈迦様がこういう風に教えるんです。
その教えは
お釈迦様が
自分の子供に
お釈迦様が在家の時代に
一人の子供がいたのです。ラーフラという名前の。
その子が出家するとき、子というのは大変失礼ですが、大阿羅漢なので。
お釈迦様は
やっぱり優れた教育者として
別に説法してないんです
仏教はああだこうだとか因果法則がああだこうだとか
四聖諦がああだこうだとか教えてないのです。子供だから。
これを教えたんです。
自分の息子に。
何かする前に
われわれは何かをする前に
ちょっと考えなさいよと
ほんのちょっと考えなさい
何かする前に。何を考えるんですかというと
（ホワイトボードに）書く前に説明しておきます。
ちょっと考えましょうと。私は
これを
私のためになりますか？
あるいは私の
損になりますか？
行為は、行動は
例えば今自分が
やろうとしていることは
自分のためになりますか
そうではないかと。それがポイント１。
それは本人が考えるんですよ。子供でもできます。
たまにお母さん方聞くでしょう？
そんなことしたら自分にいいと思いますか？と。
自分のためになりますか？
二番目は
自分の周りにいる
相手のために
この行動は相手のためになりますか
三番目は
皆のためになりますか？
それは道徳の基本
そこでお釈迦様は自分の息子にいうのです。
もしその行動が
自分のためにならない
自分の損になるならば
それは悪いことであって、不善であって、やめるべきです。
もしそ行動が
相手のためにならないのであれば
相手の損になるもので相手の害になるものならば
それは悪いことである。
やめてください。
もしあなたがやろうしていることが
みんなのためにならない
みんなの邪魔になるものですよと
皆の妨げになるものとわかったら
それは悪いことだよ。やめてください。
ですから
お釈迦様が例えをいうのですね
自分の息子にこういうのですね
あなたは
鏡を知っているでしょう？
長部経典に入っているんです。このお経は。
鏡は何のためにありますかと。
鏡は自分の顔をみるためにあるのです。
鏡を見て自分の顔が
どこらへんがまちがっているのか、髪の毛はどうですかとか
見て直すんです。
そういう風に
あなたが行動するとき
行動は三種類
一つは考えること
一つはしゃべること、一つは行動
普通の体でする行動
考えることも行為なんです。
しゃべることは行為なんです。
行動することも行為なんです。
その三つをする前に
考えます
それはできるだけはやく
子供が言葉をわかるようになってくると
いろいろ工夫して教えてあげてください。
といっても皆さんのところに赤ちゃんがいないかもしれませんが。
一応勉強のためにいいますけど
家庭は
赤ちゃんがなにか、子供が何かこう
おもちゃでもいいし、なんでもいいし
もって
いい加減に遊んでいる
そこで自分が
倒れたりして怪我したりして
怪我してなくても痛くなって泣いたりする
それでお母さんが飛んでいって「あーいたくない
「痛いの痛いの飛んでけ」とか
そういうバカげたことをいうと
子供はもう
全く悪くなるんですよ。
自分がわがままで好き勝手に遊んで
自分が痛くなって、お母さんに慰めてもらったと
それではもう反社会的な
人間になってしまいます。
そうじゃなくて優しい母だったら
あんた自分でそんなことするんだから、そうなるでしょう。
といって無視するんです。
あんたそんなことするからでしょう、と。
本人に損を味わわせるのです。
私がこういういけない遊び方をしたから
今、ひどく痛くなったのだ。と。
そして、本人は我慢する。
努力する痛みを。キャーキャーと泣かない。
すごく自信がつくし。
もうひとつ
道徳を勉強するんですね。
自分にとって悪いことはするんじゃないんだ。
お母さんが「危ない、気を付けて」そればっかりでしょう。
それで人間はダメになるんです。
本当に危ないところでは
大人はちゃんと守りますが
例えば、電車くると子供は
こうやってみようとしたら
そこはわかります。そんなことは常識だから。
ちょっと木に登ったところであぶない、あぶないと。
気をつけろとか。その言葉は毒なんです。
危ないといったらいけないんです。
木を登って足を折ったとしてもいいのです。
それは大人の仕事なんです。足が折れたら病院につれていって
直してあげる。
どうってことはないのです。
そこで子供はいやだいやだとかね
文句言うでしょう。
そのときお母さんの場なんですね。道徳を教える。
あなたが自分勝手にそういうことをしたんだからそうなった
私も大変でしょう。仕事がいっぱいあるのに。
自分のわがままいっちゃえば
それで
きちんとした育て方
道徳的に
それ一番目のポイントなんです
なかなか日本ではやらない。子供がひとり、二人しかいないんだから。
世界一悪ガキ、悪い女の子に育てるんですね。
甘えて甘えて、中国でも同じ問題に
なってくるみたいですけど。一人っ子政策で。
ですからこの
負けたらもう
それで犯罪者
これは悪いと自分で判断できないのは
人間として生きる権利さえないんです。
失格なんです。
それは小さい時に教えてあげなくては
それはもう絶対的にやらなくちゃいけないんです。
それは親の仕事なんです。
算数教えるのは学校の仕事なんです。
仕事を間違っているのです。
親が学校の勉強を教えてあげる。
道徳は全く教えていない。
道徳の場合は日本で僕が見えるのは
具体的にいうのです。
ああしなさい、こうしなさいと。
具体的に言うのはまたダメなんです。
そうすると自分で考えないのです。
こうして、こうしますよ。とか
具体的に言うべきところもありますけど
道徳の場合は
本人が判断するように
しなくちゃいけない。
例えば魚をなかなか
食べられないというならば
食べさせてあげるのではなくて
こうやってやれば食べられますよと教えてあげる
そうではなくて食べさせてあげますよとなっちゃうでしょ
この道徳の基本を忘れているのだから
世の中がくるっているんです
ですからこの
教え方はそれぞれ工夫
しなければならない。
子供の性格にもよりますし
親の教育にもよりますし
例えば僕が子供の時はよくわかっているんですね。
例えばあちこち走っちゃう。
片足で跳んでどこまでもいっちゃう。
隣の家にいくときでも、その隣に行くときでも
片足で跳んでいくのですね
片足でも長い距離とんでいくところんじゃって
膝をすりむいたり
ものすごく痛くなったりするのです
だったら、まあ、やっぱり
薬なんか入れてもらわなくてはいけないのだから
母のところにいくんですね
いったら
（母は）全然心配そうな顔はしない
その代わりに怒られるんですね
自分は知りません。
あなた勝手にやったのだからと。
かってにしなさい。
なんで泣きながらこっちに来るんですか？
これが「道徳の基礎」を教えてくれる場なんですね。
自分がいたずらしたんだから
自分がひどい目にあっているんだと
それでそんなような言葉があるんですね。
自分がこんなようなことをやったのだから
ひどいめにあったよと。
で、そこまでいわれて
やっぱり自分に悪いことはしてはいけないと
それでしっかり頭の中にはいるのです
ですから私はもう
１４才から親から離れてまったく一人の生活をしていたのだけども
きちんと自分では知ってましたよ。
人が何をいおうが
自分にとっては
どういう行動が正しいかということを
小さいころからしっかりわかっていたのです。
仏教の教えがあったからなんです。
例えば学校の仲間とかはいろんな悪いことをするんですよ。
試験でカンニングしたり
一度もやったことがない。
カンニングしたらそれは自分に悪いことだと
自分がバカになるんだと
それで人をだますようになったら一生人をだますようになってしまう。これは大変だ。
またばれちゃったらものすごい恥ずかしいのだと
そこでまた親に知られたらもう
家に帰れないんだと。家は厳しいのだから。
絶対そんなことは自分に悪いのだからやらない。
たまに他の学生たちが僕に教えてということがあったのです。
試験のときとか。
教えるのはよくないことでしょう。
と思っているんです。
答えは教えてあげないぞと思うのだけども
また、考えるんです。でも・・
わたしは体が小柄でしたし
みんあすごい体格がよくて
こいつらに後で殴られたらどうしようかと
ですから自分で勉強しないでカンニングして
悪いことをしたがっているし
それだったら自分の責任ですから、頭が悪くなろうが、どうなろうが
私は知りませんよとおもって、さっさと書いて
これが答えですといってあげるんです。
それが悪いことと知っていていても
もし教えないと
あとで自分がひどい目に合うかもしれませんと思って
人には教えた覚えがあるんです。
でも自分は絶対
しなかったんです。
ですから、勉強は真面目にしなくてはならない
羽目になったのです。
試験でカンニングして合格すればいいということではなかったのです。
大変残念な状態になった
私と一緒に勉強することになった
（実際に自分の）目で見た経験がありましたからね。
ですからやっぱり小さい時
道徳の第一行目
自分のためにならないことは悪いことであって
やめなさいと
ですから何が悪くて、何がいいのか現代人がわからないでしょう？
すごい簡単なんです。
自分のためにならないものは全部悪いんですよ
じゃあ子供にタバコを吸ってはいけないと
いったら、今度は、大人はすっているではないかといきなり聞くでしょう？
そこで学校の先生はなかなか教えることができないのです。
私だったら「あなたタバコ吸いたいのですか。堂々と吸ってください」
いうんです。
「タバコを吸うことがあなたにとってもいいことだと思ってますか？」と。
「そう。いいと思うならば、堂々と吸ってください。」と。
いうと吸わないのです。
それは道徳の基本から僕はそういうのです。
基本というのは本人が
なんで学生・子供たちがタバコを吸うかというと大人をいじめるためなんですよ。
学校の先生やら自分の親やら
なんとかして
いじめて自分のほうを（向かせて）、甘えたいんですね
甘えたくて、甘えさせているんだから
ですから甘えさせてはいけいない
「じゃあ、吸ってください」
お母さんだったらどうぞ吸ってください、はいタバコ
ひと箱買ってあげればいいのです。
カートンひとつ。はいどうぞと。
それでもうやめますよ。
あなたの体でしょうに。死んじゃっても私の問題ではないのだと。
だから、子供が「いけませんよ。
タバコ吸ったらいけませんよ。」と言ってほしいんですね。
言ってほしいとそれによっていろいろ
また更にいたずらしようとおもっているんです。
そんな計画は
全部破らなくてはいけない。
そういう工夫が大人にないのだからしようがない
もし仏教の基本を知っているならば
結構、そういう工夫がどんどん出てくるんです。
方便というのは仏教ではよくあることだから
限りない方便がでてくるんです。
ということで私はもう結構子供たちを扱った
経験はかなりあるし、いつでも
国に行ったら子供たちと一緒の生活が多いのだけども
失敗はほとんどない。ゼロ。
自分のためになります。
自分のためにならないものは罪です。悪いんです。
タバコ吸うことも、酒飲むことも
ふざけることも
じゃあ、学校さぼることも
もし子供が知っているならば
自分のためにならないことはよくないのだと
学校さぼったりはしないのです。
学校をさぼったならば
「ああ、（学校に）行ってください」とか
ではなくて「もういいです。いかなくたって。」
「いかなくってもいいんだ」と。
「あなたはあなた。わたしはわたしです。」と。
自分で
まいた種は
自分で刈る
刈り取るんだと。
大人の責任としてちょっとした
未来図をみせてやってもいいんです。
教育のある人はこういう人生で
選ぶのはあなたですよと。
何も教育が無い人は大きくなったとしても
重労働とか危険な仕事とかね
しなくてはいけない
やっとどっか会社にはいったとしてもばかにされるのだと、いじめられるのだと。
ろくな金にならないのだと。
勉強してないのだから自分のお金の計算もできなくて
もしかすると浮浪者みたいになるかもしれません。
ホームレスになるかもしれません。
それはそういうこと。
勉強するならばいくらかまともに生活できる。
でもどちらにするかは私ではないのだと。
それくらい教えてあげて
無視すれば、本人は「あ、これは大変だ」と。
すごい責任感が生まれてくるのです。
二番目は
相手のためになりますかと
それはもう子供たちの道徳ではないのです。
仏教の基本的な道徳の基礎です。
我々の場合も同じですよ。
そこで
人間というのは
相手のことを気にするんですよ
「みんなに嫌われたい」という人はいませんし
「みんなにいじめられたい」
「みんなに無視されたい」
「社会から追い出されたい」
そう思う人はまずいません。
どんな人間の心の中でも
向こう側からよく思われたい
認めてほしい。評価してほしい。
という気分があるでしょう。
それは本能です。
まれに人が人にバカにされると気持ちよくなるかもしれませんが
あまりそういう人はいませんし。
ですから
この行動、このことをしたら
相手のためになりますかと
相手によくおもわれますかと
それをちゃんと教えて
しっかり
教えてあげてください。
例えば子供が皆に迷惑かけてると
いきなり親からやめなさい
子供はやめます。親が怖いんだから
これでは全然親子関係が生まれませんし
親が鬼になっちゃいますよ。なんだかんだ命令するんだから。
そうじゃなくて
こういうことしてみんなに嫌われて
あなたは面白いですかと。
皆に「あなたは行儀の悪いバカですよ」と。
何にも行儀のない
何の教育もない。何もちゃんと育てられていない。
悪ガキだと思われて面白いですかと。
それだけなんですよ。
そうするとやっぱり自分の行動は
周りの人々に認められるような行動
でなければいけませんと、子供もそれでしっかりするのです。
大人の場合は
我々がしていることは
例えば自分が儲かるために何かする
それによって相手が損する
それは罪なんです。不善なんです。
それは悪いことなんです。やめてほしいんです。
ただ
子供は自分が面白いんだからやりますよと
と思ったとしても、それだけでは
決められません。
自分に面白いんだけど他人に迷惑だったら
例えば、ステレオを大きい音で聞いてるんだと
子供に面白いかもしれませんが
お母さんにとってはうるさくてしようがないし
おじいちゃんにとっては最悪かもしれませんし
ですから
この音を
聞きなさいとか、控えなさいとか
命令したらそこで関係が悪くなるのです
若者がでっかい音でステレオを聞いている場合は
若者は若者なりに大きい音で聞きたいのだから
いつでも道徳の基本からしゃべらなくてはならないのです。
あなただけよければいいと思っているんですかと。
あなただけ楽しめれば
おじいちゃん、おばあちゃんのことはどうでもいいとおもっているんですかと。
となりの人々のことはどうでもいいと思っているんですかと。
自分だけで生きていられると思っているんですかと。
そのように若者に言わなくてはいけないのです
ですから音楽きくなということではないのです。
ステレオを消しなさいということではないのです。
判断は本人がしなくちゃいけない。
そこで本人がヘッドフォンできくか、音を控えるか本人が決めるんです。
人間がするべき仕事は
親やら大人やら学校の先生たちがやってるんだから
我々、動物を育てていくのがもとになっているんです。
家畜動物。人間を育てるんじゃないんです。
〔でも、〕人間というのは立派な知識人だから
それなりに責任感与えて育てなくてはいけない。
それで二番目は相手のためになりますか？
三番目は
行動の普遍的な
真理なんです
いいことは
自分の為にもなるし
他人の為にもなるんです
世間のすべての人々のためになるんです
もし、そういう基礎で教えをべんきょうしたならば
我々は別に困らなくてもいいんです
どんなことに対しても
人はどんな仕事をしたとしても
世の中を害することはしませんし
会社の社長が
自分の部下にいろいろ賄賂を
いろいろしたりして会社のためにやりなさいと
いっても、部下は全部知ってるんですよ。
こんなことしたら日本のためになりませんと。
会社のためになりません。
お金のカラクリやら
色々人に賄賂を払ったりとか
ですから断るんです。
課長はこういうんだけど
これは悪いことだからわたしはやりませんと。他のことを頼んでください。
他の人に頼んでください。私は
一ランク落とされても構いません。
それくらい自信がありますよ。そういう人は。
そうすると会社は倒産しませんし。
そういう〔不正が横行する〕ところだと銀行さえ倒産する羽目になっちゃいますから
で、この教育の
道徳がないのだからなのです。
それは公のお金
銀行に払わなくてはならなくなるのです。とんでもないことなんです。
ですから、我々は仕事をしたとしても
科学的な研究にしても
科学的な発明にしても
やっぱり自分のためになること
他人のためになること
全ての生命、みんなのためになることは基本であって
それを破ったらもう間違えだと
それを当てはめてみてください。
現在の宗教運動にたいして。
道徳の基本さえないのです。
で、親が悪いんですよ。結局。
親が道徳の基本を教えてないのだから。
人殺しまでいっちゃうんですよ。
いくら超能力者が現れて
あの人殺しなさいと
殺したら
あなたは超能力者になれますよといっても
そんなことやりませんよ。
仏教の世界がしっかりしているのは
そういうわけなんですよ。
我々は自分の国だったら
子供の時に全部手を打っておくのです。
しっかり教え込んでしまう。
暗記させちゃうんです。そういう道徳は。
今日もお経をひとつ説明したかったんだけど
それはもう意味まで全部〔憶えさせる。〕
それからもう
放しちゃう。
お寺に来るのはちっちゃなもう
何もわけのわからない小さな子たちから
まあ１２、３、４歳まで
で、まあそれでも一応
若者になってくると
お寺に来ないであちこち遊びまわっちゃいますから
我々は全然心配しない
また戻ってくるんだから
その間の人生はなにも心配ない
まあ１００％ではないのだけども
９０％の人間は悪いことしません。
そこでしっかり自分で判断しながら生活する
ある面でばらばらかもしれませんが
日本のようにきちんとなんでもコントロールされて
きちんと規則正しくはないのです。
まあ、仏教はもともとそのようにわざわざ教えているのだから。
でもこの道徳の基本
それを覚えて皆様も覚えておいてください
死ぬまでそれを守らなくてはならない
それは仏教の教えなんですよ
あるテレビである人が宗教を批判しながら
仏教には矛盾がありますよと。
私は頭にきて「このバカは仏教をわかってないのだと」
頭にきたんだけどテレビに怒っても何の意味もないのだからね
人のテレビだから壊すわけにもいきませんし
矛盾があるわけがないのですよ
仏教では先生のために何をしてもいいということはないのですよ。
お母さんのために人を殺してもいいということはないのですよ。
冗談じゃないんです
かすかな悪いことでもするな
はっきり悪いんだと。お釈迦様は自分の
息子に教えた教えだから
子供の教育には欠かせない教えなのです。
ですから取るべきものは
自分のためになること
周りの人々のためになること
社会の皆さまのためになること
そういう行動をすると社会になんの問題があるのですかね？
いちいちくだらないことを説法する必要ないでしょうに
こうやって人間は
社会つくるべきですよとか
まったく自然にできあがってしまいますよ。
それで我々にはいっぱい時間があるんですよ。
時間があるので、四聖諦やら
八正道やら因果法則やら
アビダルマ論やら高度な瞑想の世界やら
そういう教えられる時間があるのだから。
嘘をつくなとか
ものを盗むなとか
そんなくだらない教えを教える暇はないのです。そんなことはお母さんが教えるべきなんです。
道徳の基本は。
たくさんポイントありますけど
ひとつだけいいます。
我々は悪いことをしたときは
叱ってはいけない
すぐ叱っちゃうんですね
動物と同じなんです
少々、違うかも知れませんけど
子供達でもたまに
たまにではなくてしょっちゅう悪いことをするんですよ
それは子供だから当たり前なんです。
本人もそれをわかっているんです。
大体
そこで、わかっているんだから
なんでそういうことするんですか、いけないことではないかと
言うのは、全部、無駄なのです。
でも、どうも
大人というのは我慢できなくて、人が悪いことをするとすぐひとを怒鳴っちゃうんです。
それは大人が悪いのです。
大人が怒っているんだから。子供は大人をおこらせるために
大人を困らせるためにやっているんだから、もうなめられているのです。
それから叱ろうと思うと
子供は心の中で膜をつくるのです。
壁を
すぐ
「ああ、これから説教ですよ」と。
そう思った瞬間、Vipassanaと同じく
まあこれから説教だよと
子供が心の中にいれちゃいますから
あの内容は何もはいりません。
Vipassanaの経験があればごぞんじだと思いますけど
耳に入るものが音だと確認すると
全然気にならないのだから音は
子供もそれは同じことをやっています。
「これから説教・・
はじまります」と。
はいらない。我々はただ疲れるだけ。
自分が怒ってバカになるだけ。
その時ではなくて
すごくいい
時がでてくるんですよ。
言う時が。
相手も全く
想像していない瞬間
まあ親があれは
忘れただろうという
しっかり思っている瞬間
あるいはすごく
親と仲良くしているとき
すごく仲良く一緒に遊んでいるときに
「そういえば、このあいだこういうことしたしたんだけど、あれどういう意味ですか」とか。
いきなり聞けばいいんです。
子供はびっくりするんです。
頭の中まではいっちゃうんですね。
「このあいだ、あんたがこんなことをして」
「こんなことになりましたよ」
ですからこの叱る
ちゃんと、時と場合というのがあるんです。
それを自分で発見しなくては、大変だと。
社会人でもおなじなんですよ。
自分の部下が悪いことをしたならば
いきなり怒鳴っちゃうでしょう
それでは会社はあまりうまくいかない。
部下はもうわざわざ
間違い犯しましょうと
失敗しましょうとやってるバカな部下はいません。
失敗だから、間違いだから。
「これではいけない」と本人はわかっているんですよ。
ですから失敗したときは
励ますのであって、叱るのではないのです。
世の中の生き方とはちょっと違う
かもしれません。仏教のやり方は。
失敗したときは励ましてあげてください。
例えば弁償しなくてはいけない失敗をしましたと。
その時は部下が大変困っていますよ。
自分がこんなことをしてしまったのだからこれは弁償しなくてはいけない。
「あなたちゃんとこうやって支払いなさい」とかね。
「なんでこんなことするんですか」とか、そんな風に言うのではなくて
励ましてあげる。
例えば、これは例えの話です
「まあ、こんな問題を人間というのはいつでもね、
バカなことをやってますからね。しようがないよ！」と。
人間というのは。
あなたにもお金はないのに
そんなことを言ったら大変でしょうねえとか。
「まあ、気にするな！」と
「それなりにすこしづつ返しなさい」と。
本人と一緒にならなくてはいけないのです。
悩んでいるときに。
自分と一緒に悩んでくれる人がいるということで
二度と間違いを犯さない
どころか
一回の失敗に基づいてその人が
すごく成功するのです。
叱ってしまったら、そのあともずっと失敗するのです。
ポイントは
相手に読めない
心を持つことなんです。
上下関係の場合
親と子供の場合は
上司と部下の場合は
学校の先生と生徒の場合は
上の人の心を読めちゃったら
これでもう終わりと
ですから失敗したら叱られるだろうというのは常識です。
叱らないことは
仏教の真理なんです。
そういういま皆様にいったことは
まだたくさんありますよ。
全部試してみたことなんです。
僕は実例あげるともう
一日の講義で終わらないのです。
膨大な量になるほど
実例を自分は持っているのです。
ですからこの
全部試した経験のある
ちゃんとしたものなんです
一応それだけ覚えておいてください。
失敗したときは叱らないこと
間違い起こしたその時は
叱らないこと
例えば子供が皿でもいいし、花瓶でもいいし割っちゃったと
そのとき叱ったとしても何の意味もないのです。
すぐ片づけなさいと。
それいえばいいんです。
ちゃんと片付けてきれいにしなさい。
子供はそれでやってくれるんです。
それから、あんたはものを触るときは
いつでもこうやって、こうやってるんだから
こうなるでしょう。
モノを取るときはしっかりとるんですよ
説明してあげればそれで終わり
割れたものは割れて終わったんだからそれで
どうってことはないのだから
ということなんです。
時間がとんでましたけど
四時間しゃべっても終わらないくらいないようがあるんだけど
ここで
終わりにします。